بعد اعترافهم بانهم قصروا بحق السوريين
دخل اول وفد اممي الشمال السوري عبر معبر
باب الهوى الى ادلب اسبوعنا مضى على حادثه
الزلزال المدمر شمالي سوريا انشا حاله غضب
شعبي واسعه طالت الامم المتحده وجعلت
الشعور بالخذلان اقوى من ان تبرره الكلمات
مارتن جرافيت وكيلو الامين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه اعتبر ان
السوريين محقون في مشاعر الخذلان التي
اصابتهم ملمحا الى نيه المؤسسه الامميه
تصحيح الفشل سريعا الوفد الذي بدا زيارته
بالاعتراف بوخذلان خمسه ملايين سوري شمال
غربي سوريا رافقته 26 شاحنه من المساعدات
الانسانيه ووفق مصادر العربيه سيبدا الوفد
بتقييم الاضرار وتحديد الاحتياجات في
محاوله لتعويض ما يراه السوريون حقا
انسانيا تاخر وصوله وصل نداءات سوريه
للعمل من خارج مجلس الامن لافتتاح ثلاثه
معابر باسرع وقت
ان شاء الله ان هذه القوافل ستكبر بشكل
اكثر خلال الايام القادمه بحيث تغطي اكبر
احتياج لاهلنا الذين تضرروا من الزلزال
ملف المعابر في سوريا لطالما كان محطه
تجاذبات سياسيه بين دول حليفه للنظام
واخرى داعمه للشعب السوري ليتحول الى ورقه
ضغط سياسي بين الاطراف في اروقه مجلس
الامن ومع تفاقم ازمه النازحين الى
المخيمات اقر مجلس الامن قبل 9 سنوات
السماح بعبور المساعدات الانسانيه الامميه
من اربعه معابر بريه في سوريا هي باب
السلامه وباب الهوى مع تركيا ولي عروبيه
مع العراق والرمثا مع الاردن وفي مطلع عام
2020 صوت مجلس الامن لقرار عبور المساعدات
الامميه عبر تركيا من خلال معبري باب
الهواء وباب السلامه ما تسبب في اغلاق
معبرين في شمال شرقي وجنوب سوريا حنان
المصري العربيه